hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
lot of talk going around about
spider-man's suit during civil war in
the suit that he's gonna be wearing in
the new spider-man trilogy so I wanted
to do a video for my top 10 spider-man
costumes now if you're just going on
like the basic Peter Parker costumes
there's about 17 almost 20 different
costumes that you learn in the comics
when you talk about the alternate
versions of spider-man like you talk
about alternate universe versions that
number goes way way up let's start with
a Captain America Civil War talk first
so what's being reported now like the
the big rumor mill is reporting that
spider-man is gonna have two different
costumes the first one is the low-five
version that he's swinging around in New
York in right now and then he gets swept
up in civil war then we get to the new
spider-man trilogy so naturally there's
gonna be progression of suits just like
we saw with the Captain America
character our Iron Man is probably an
even better example he gets a shiny new
suit every single movie sometimes
multiple suits within each movie a lot
of people are saying that even though
spider-man's only gonna be a small part
of Civil War a lot of what he does and
the people that he interacts with will
be in the vein of what he did in civil
war in the comics that's just on like a
really low level though the spider-man
that we see in the movies is going to be
way different from the spider-man of the
comics in the comics he was an adult in
the movies he's gonna be a teenager in
the lead-up to Civil War in the comics
spider-man was living at the Avengers
tower with Aunt May and Mary Jane
obviously he's gonna be 15 in Civil War
so he's not gonna have Mary Jane and
he's still probably gonna be with Aunt
May out in Queens that version of The
Avengers Tower was basically like the
stark tower that we see in the movies
Tony Stark was a much bigger presence in
the Avengers a lot of his tech permeated
The Avengers
so when Spiderman gets a brand new suit
he gets the iron spider suit it's given
to him by Tony Stark
it's an Iron Man suit built to enhance
spider-man's powers and it even helps
him with his precognition a lot of
people are saying that Captain America
Civil War is gonna do kind of the same
thing in that Tony Stark will give
spider-man a suit this is like a fan
mock-up version of what the homemade
Spider Man suit is supposed to be it
almost feels a little bit in the vein of
the Ben Riley suit where it's like part
t-shirt part form-fitting spandex so
naturally you just expect the Tony Stark
version to be waist sleeker I could
totally see a version of this where like
halfway through the movie Tony Stark
gives them a version of the Spider suit
that's red like
his Iron Man suit red but I think that's
about as close as we'll get to the iron
spider suit of the comics you guys can
let me know whether you agree or not do
you think that Tony Stark's spider-man
suit that he's gonna give him is gonna
be really close to iron spider or do you
think it's gonna be completely different
from the comic books
I think if we've learned anything from
Marvel it's that whenever they take
stuff to the movies they just tune the
colors down a little bit does the colors
tend to be a little less bright but here
we go on two favorite spider-man suits
so here are like my top 10 favorite
suits from the comic books and this is
taking from all the versions of
spider-man not just Peter Parker
starting with number 10 the Fantastic
Four Baghead suit he had to wear it
after he lost the symbiote suit and he
couldn't find anything to cover his face
with so he just had to put a bag on his
head whenever he wore it people called
him the bombastic bag man number nine
the captain universe suit this is one of
those crazy storylines where like
superhero goes to God like superhero
it's actually kind of happened with doom
right now in Secret Wars but he became
captain universe for a little while so
his cosmic powers altered his suit to
look more like Captain universe number
eight the dusk suit this is actually
something adapted from a suit that he
got in the negative zone he gained the
ability to blend in with shadows and he
could straight-up fly like really fly
number seven the actual stealth suit he
actually built this to combat this sonic
ability that Hobgoblin was using it kind
of looks like Tron cosplay like Tron
spider-man number six the future
foundation suit he got this in Fantastic
Four number one when he joined the
Future Foundation and like obviously
everybody in the organization got new
costumes but I really like the white
design on everyone it's just a nice
change I like the fact that even though
the Future Foundation is a bunch of
Heroes it feels just a little bit
sinister like when everybody looks the
same something feels a little bit wrong
number five the fear itself suit this is
actually made of the same Guru metal
that was used to make Thor's hammer so
that alone merits its place on this list
too bad after they defeated the worthy
that Odin made Tony Stark destroy the
suit
sometimes Marvel will like give you
something and then just snatch it right
back like yeah this is way too powerful
for you to keep number for the
spider-man 2099 suit originally whenever
they did the 2099 universe
felt kind of gimmicky I mean I was
really down for it I was a lot younger
when I started reading it then it went
away but they ended up bringing it back
and now it's a big part of secret Wars
the way I think about this is that it's
kind of like the Blade Runner spider-man
costume just because those comics borrow
a lot somatically from Blade Runner
number 3 Miles Morales is ultimate
spider-man suit this just has a twist on
the classic Peter Parker suit but I
really like the black colors it's it's
still Spider Man but it's different
simpler is usually better it's not quite
as cool as Spider Gwen's costume but of
all the alternate people to take the
Spider Man mantle I feel like it's one
of the best speaking of which
number two spider Gwen's costume say
what you will about the spider Gwen's
storyline I like what they're trying to
do with it I like the idea of it and I
like that of all the alternate
spider-man it's the most different on
the flip side of that if you wanted to
be really neat about it and make fun of
it you could call it the Hot Topic
spider-man costume I think it's perfect
for Gwen Stacy if Peter Parker were to
wear a costume like that it would feel a
little ridiculous it finally probably is
as you would expect my favorite
spider-man costume the classic symbiote
suit from the original Secret Wars of
all the original variations on
spider-man's costume this is probably
the most famous like of all the
different costumes that people remember
they remember the classic Peter Parker
red and blue and they remember the
symbiote suit the black suit although
technically he had a black cloth version
too but it was just a non symbiote
version of the symbiote suit really the
symbiote gave him pretty much all the
powers that he had with the iron spider
suit like the enhanced senses the
enhanced strength everything cranked up
to 11 but you have to battle the will of
the symbiote so if your personality
isn't strong enough to fight it
you'll go completely apeshit so now it's
your guy's turn let me know like what is
your favorite version of the spider-man
costume it doesn't have to be any of
Peter Parker's costumes it could be one
of the alternate ones and like like what
do you think about what they're doing
with the spider-man costumes now really
like the Secret Wars costume that we've
seen like Miles Morales is still wearing
his ultimate suit though they're pretty
true to the classic versions we'll have
to see what they're doing with all the
costumes post Secret Wars
I gave Marvel bonus points any time they
try something new but I feel like people
like spider-man like they're so
identified with that original costume
that you can't change it too much for
too long or people will just freak so
that's why you see them playing
the look of a lot of the alternate
spider-men a lot more than they play
with Peter Parker's look just a reminder
about the movie
if you don't know Captain America Civil
War is coming out May 6
we have Deadpool in February there's
gonna be a lot of comic book movies in
the early part of the year we're also
gonna get I think x-men apocalypse is
coming out before Captain America Civil
War - I also wanted to remind everyone
tomorrow they're doing a press
conference for the arrow flash and
legends of tomorrow so I'll be doing a
bunch of DC stuff tomorrow a bunch of
like DC TV related stuff be sure to
subscribe to get everything if there's
any other like Marvel movie video stuff
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments we're really getting to
the point where we're starting to see
more and more from Captain America Civil
War we're probably gonna get the trailer
after d23 which is actually gonna happen
in a couple weeks a lot of you guys have
been asking me about cable showing up in
Deadpool stuff I did an x-force video
because that's basically where they're
gonna be crossing over that movies a
little bit further off but you can click
here to learn all about that and you can
click here to learn all about Baron Zemo
in the comics he's gonna be a big person
in Captain America's Civil War so thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you